Новини дня «heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Усім доброго вечора.
Поруч зі мною знову Норберт Леман,
який розповість про новини спорту.
Погляньмо на теми сьогоднішнього випуску.
Боротьба з рекордною інфляцією:
Європейський центральний банк
підвищує ключові відсоткові ставки,
і дуже активно.
Це приємна новина для вкладників,
але погана для будівельників.
Фінансова допомога для споживачів газу
та централізованого теплопостачання:
уряд планує взяти на себе початковий внесок у грудні
й у такий спосіб підтримати споживачів
до введенняцінового гальма на газ.
Тюремний вирок для Альфонса Шубека:
зіркового шеф-кухаря засудили
до трьох років і двох місяців
позбавлення волі за ухилення від сплати податків.
Ми всі це відчуваємо: ціни в Єврозоні
нині зростають швидше,
ніж будь-коли в історії валютного союзу.
У вересні інфляція становила 9,9%.
Європейський центральний банк
намагається протидіяти цьому,
різко підвищуючи відсоткову ставку.
Після довгих вагань у липні підвищили
ключову відсоткову ставку,
вперше за одинадцять років.
Це повторилося у вересні та сьогодні - до 2%.
Репортаж Маркуса Вользіффера.
Вагань більше немає:
сьогодні у Франкфурті
глава ЄЦБ Лаґард демонструє рішучість.
Уже вдруге поспіль - підвищення на 0,75%.
Ключова відсоткова ставка, за якою комерційні банки
отримують кредити від ЄЦБ, зростає до 2%.
Ідея валютних гарантів -
зробити кредити дорожчими, щоб уповільнити попит,
і так стримати високі темпи інфляції.
Рівень інфляція досі занадто високий
і ще довго залишатиметься вищим за цільовий показник.
Багато експертів та представників
різних галузейвважають
це рішення запізнілим.
Будівельна галузь, наприклад, має боротися
зі стрімким зростанням цін
на матеріали й енергоносії.
Багато замовлень зриваються,
водночас Інститут економічних досліджень
повідомляє про хвилю скасувань проєктів.
Проблема полягає в тому,
що вища відсоткова ставка хоча й бореться з інфляцією,
але водночас спричиняє зростання іпотечних ставок.
Мрія про власне житло - недосяжна для багатьох.
Якщо у вас був кредит 500 тис. євро
під 1% чи 2%,
тоді внесок становив десь 1300-1400 євро.
За сьогоднішнім рівнем
відсоткових ставок це 2500 євро.
І, звичайно, це значне підвищення,
з яким багато сімей не можуть впоратися.
Принаймні для вкладників зміна відсоткової ставки
має позитивні наслідки.
Відсотки знову з'явилися,
деякі банки вже рекламують їх.
Варто ще раз озирнутися
і порівняти банки.
Адже якщо один банк
уже платить 3% упродовж трьох років,
а інший банк все ще не пропонує
прийнятнихдепозитів,
то це величезна різниця.
ЄЦБ вже оголосив:
ймовірно, це не останнє підвищення відсоткової ставки,
навіть попри всі ризики рецесії.
Франк Бетман з нами на зв'язку
з фондової біржі у Франкфурті.
Коли можна очікувати, що ціни
припинять так сильно зростати?
У цьому контексті зима залишиться крижаною.
Ціни будуть такими щонайменше до весни.
Тоді інфляція може досягти піку.
Потрібен час, щоб підвищення
відсоткових ставок запрацювало.
Іноді на це йдуть тижні, а то й місяці.
Цей час болісний для багатьох.
Але це і час, який ЄЦБ раніше не використовував.
Занадто пізно він почав боротися з інфляцією.
Тому ціни, найімовірніше, залишаться високими
упродовж зимових місяців.
Настільки високі, що перед Центральним банком
зараз стоїть інша проблема,
а саме те, що він втратив довіру.
Згідно з опитуванням, багато громадян вважають,
що Європі доведеться довго
боротися з підвищенням цін.
Тож віра в те, що Європейський центральний банк
може знову швидко забезпечити стабільні ціни,
втрачена.
Тому друге велике підвищення
відсоткової ставки поспіль, яке відбулося сьогодні,
також слід розглядати як сигнал.
Як сигнал валютних гарантів: ми це виправимо.
З нами був Франк Бетман, дякую.
Помітний побічний ефект
високої інфляції:
держава заробляє на зростанні цін,
адже зростають податкові надходження,
і дуже сильно.
Податківці очікують на рекордні
надходження в наступні роки.
Однак в основі цих оцінок лежить нестабільність,
про це попереджає міністр фінансів.
Репортаж Вінні Гішер.
Ціни високі.
Кожен відчуває це у повсякденному житті.
Держава, однак, виграє від інфляції
та стабільного ринку праці.
Податки на заробітну плату та прибуток, як і ПДВ,
потрапляють до державної скарбниці.
Але міністр фінансів попереджає:
це серйозна криза,
і ці гроші потрібні державі,
громадянам та підприємствам.
З огляду на масштабне підвищення цін на енергоносії,
це правильно і важливо.
Тому ми не маємо фінансової свободи дій
для нових проєктів.
Очікується, що податкові надходження цього року
становитимуть майже 888 мільярдів євро -
менше, ніж передбачувалось.
З наступного року очікують зворотну тенденцію:
надійде понад 937 мільярдів євро.
До 2026 року очікують
збільшення надходжень на загальну суму
126 мільярдів євро.
Крістіан Лінднер міг би взяти більше грошей у борг,
втім, він цього не хоче, що спричинило
хвилю обурення у народу.
Нам не потрібно удаваного дотримання цінового гальма.
Зараз воно досягається через штучні операції,
коли держава заборгується наперед,
щоб наступного року сказати,
що вона дотримується цінового гальма.
Багато людей, професії, малий і середній бізнес -
усе суспільство
переживає екзистенційну кризу.
Для виходу з кризи зараз потрібні цільові інвестиції.
Боргове гальмо потрібно врешті-решт скасувати.
Усі погоджуються з Лінднером в одному:
цей податковий прогноз нестабільний
через пандемію, війну та енергетичну кризу.
Утім, ці мільярди таки дійдуть до громадян:
сьогодні Міністерство економіки презентувало
проєкт екстреної допомоги:
споживачі газу та централізованого опалення
нічого не платитимуть у грудні.
З такою пропозицією виступила комісія експертів.
Лютен Лайнгос розповість про те, як це працюватиме.
Звучить просто:
у грудні замість громадян заплатить держава.
Вона перерахує гроші енергопостачальникам,
а ті одразу перерахують відшкодування нам, споживачам.
Для власників приватних будинків та орендарів
квартир з індивідуальним опаленням
це дійсно може спрацювати.
Вони мають прямий контракт зі своїм постачальником.
По суті, вони просто пропустять оплату за грудень.
Складніше власникам або орендарям квартир,
які мають центральне газове опалення або
мережу централізованого теплопостачання.
У цих випадках постачальники сплачують
загальну суму орендодавцю
або органу домоуправління.
Потім визначають суму для кожної квартири окремо.
За даними асоціацій власників житла,
ця процедура може тривати до наступної платіжки
за комунальні послуги.
Розмір пільги розраховують
з чинного грудневого тарифу енергопостачальника
та 1/12 від попереднього річного споживання.
Можна подумати, що оскільки
гуртова ціна на газ нарешті падає
після рекордного зростання цін
за останні кілька місяців,
то ця фінансова підтримка більше не потрібна.
Втім, не все так просто.
Свен Рікен - детальніше.
Гермен Розенкранц з Бад-Шлема, Саксонія,
раніше платив за газ 199 євро на місяць.
І раптом
йому довелося сплатити 1146 євро за місяць.
І це з пенсією 1800 євро.
Я думав, що це якийсь хибодрук -
ніхто ж не може стільки платити щомісяця.
Грошей же не залишиться.
І все ж зараз ціна на газ падає.
Причина - наповненість газових сховищ.
Німеччині більше не потрібно зараз купувати газ.
Тож попит різко впав.
У цю теплу осінню погоду падає
не лише листя, а й ціна на газ.
Але це не змінює законів біржового ринку:
постачальники прикриваються
довгостроковими контрактами.
Щодня ціни формуються на спотовому ринку,
де вони коливаються
занадто сильно для більшості постачальників газу
і не піддається обчисленню. Тому підприємства укладають
довгострокові угоди й за вищими на цю мить цінами.
Це також означає, що від падіння ціни на газ
вони не зможуть отримати вигоду.
І через це їм немає що надати
кінцевому споживачу у короткій перспективі.
Проте якщо постачальник газу підпише
довгострокову закупівлю,
його клієнти платитимуть менше.
Це також помітно на сайтах з порівняннями.
При цьому ми спостерігаємо, що ціни для нових клієнтів,
тобто тих, які потенційно можуть
змінити постачальника, знижуються.
У порівнянні з початком вересня
ціни зменшилися вдвічі.
Тож принаймні для нових клієнтів
з'явилася маленька надія.
Зараз Герман Розенкранц перейшов
до нового постачальника,
зменшивши перший внесок.
Утім, споживачі отримують рахунки
після року користування,
тож ця «знижка» - тимчасова.
Президент Росії Володимир Путін
вкотре звинуватив Захід
в ескалації ситуації в Україні.
Виступаючи перед міжнародними
політичними експертами, він заявив,
що «рано чи пізно Заходу
доведеться обговорювати спільне майбутнє з Росією»».
Також він заявив, що Москва не має наміру
застосовувати ядерну зброю в Україні.
Як допомогти Україні - одна з тем візиту
канцлера Шольца до Греції.
А саме йшлося про військову допомогу,
зокрема про «круговий обмін».
Німеччина надала Афінам бойові машини Marder,
натомість греки передали Україні
танки радянського виробництва.
Але головну роль під час цього візиту відіграли
грецько-турецькі відносини.
Андреас Кінаст розкаже більше.
Є лише одне місце в Афінах, де Олафа Шольца
можуть зрозуміти навіть без слів.
Канцлер на акрополі,
канцлер поруч з прем'єр-міністром,
Німеччина - на боці Греції.
Напруженість у відносинах між Грецією і Туреччиною
настільки серйозна й масштабна, що
прем'єр-міністр Греції Міцотакіс
вже кілька місяців просить
про будь-яку можливу політичну допомогу.
Йдеться про грецьких військових
на грецьких островах у Середземному морі.
Туреччина вимагає вивести їх,
інакше погрожує вторгненням.
Це знають наші сусіди, це знають всі:
грецькі острови не становлять загрози.
Ми не становимо жодної загрози.
Тоді греки готують німців до неприємностей,
до жорстокого «побічного ефекту»
домовленого обміну зброєю.
Ці шість німецьких бойових машин Marder,
доставлені кілька днів тому,
за кілька днів перекинуть до кордону з Туреччиною.
Для Шольца це суто рішення Греції.
Ми надали машини Marder Греції
і не маємо щоденних звітів про те,
де вони перебувають на цей момент.
Ми й не запитуємо.
Проте є підозра, навіть у німецькій делегації,
що Туреччина, ймовірно, бачить ситуацію інакше.
Нині конфлікт між Грецією та Туреччиною -
це також і проблема Німеччини.
Канцлер Шольц сьогодні став на бік Греції,
але в такий обережний дипломатичний спосіб,
що посередницька роль Німеччини все ще можлива.
Офіційно Ізраїль і Ліван все ще
перебувають у стані війни,
проте вони вже досягли домовленості
щодо морського кордону.
Десятиліттями вони боролися за позначену тут
ділянку в Середземному морі,
частково через те, що вона містить
два газових родовища.
За посередництва США доступ до нього врегульовано.
Міхаель Беверунґе розповість,
що це означає для відносин
між двома країнами.
Зазвичай, підписання важливого договору відзначають
широким розголосом та публічними рукостисканнями.
Але угода про новий морський кордон
прем'єр-міністр Ізраїлю
спокійно підписав у Єрусалимі.
Без особливих церемоній обійшлося і в Лівані.
Не дивно: обидві країни офіційно все ще перебувають
у стані війни.
Це додає значущості укладеній
після багаторічних переговорів угоді.
Це успіх.
Не кожен день ворожа країна визнає Ізраїль
у підписаному договорі перед світовою громадськістю.
Саме тому договір спричиняє суперечки в Лівані.
Про невизнання Ізраїлю, а проте
схвалення договору сигналізує проіранське
ополчення Хезболла.
Похвала лунає з боку США, які виступили
посередником в укладенні договору
і вбачають переваги для обох сторін.
Ця угода відкриває енергетичні родовища
в обох країнах.
Вона приносить нові надії та економічні можливості
ліванському народу,
а також підвищує стабільність і безпеку
ізраїльського народу.
Фактично визнання морського кордону
робить переможцями обидві країни:
тепер вони можуть розпочати розробку великих
газових родовищ у спірному районі.
Нові газові родовища також викликають зацікавленість
в Європі та Німеччині.
Щоправда, постачання зрідженого газу поки що
залишається нездійсненною мрією,
а його загальний обсяг досить незначний.
В принципі, однак, як казали
міністру економіки Габеку
під час його останнього візиту, Ізраїль цілком
може собі уявити
таку газову угоду.
Назад до Німеччини: знаменитий шеф-кухар
Альфонс Шубек піде до в'язниці.
За даними мюнхенського суду, він ухилився від сплати
мільйонних податків.
Власне, Шубек десятиліттями уособлював зоряну кухню,
веселі виступи в кулінарних і ток-шоу
та близькість до мюнхенської сцени знаменитостей.
Але Шубек має й іншу сторону:
підприємця вже засудили
за ухилення від сплати податків 1995 року.
На той час він ще перебував на умовному терміні.
Тепер він отримав понад три роки позбавлення волі.
Петра Нойбауер.
Тож тепер його найбільші побоювання справдилися -
Альфонс Шубек засуджений до трьох років
і двох місяців
позбавлення волі.
Зрештою, вирішальним фактором для палати стало те,
що було заподіяно дуже багато збитків
протягом дуже тривалого періоду часу
з відносно високим рівнем злочинної мотивації.
У суді довели, що Шубек
здійснив відмивання грошей в обхід податкової
на загальну суму 2,3 млн євро.
Спеціально для цього у своєму ресторані «Orlando»
він встановив додаткову комп'ютерну техніку.
За її допомогою він мав змогу видаляти з каси виторг,
яку потім знімав готівкою.
Шубек також маніпулював касами
у ресторані «Südtiroler Stuben».
Лише тут зникло понад 1000 номерів рахунків,
точна кількість залишається невідомою.
Той факт, що Шубек визнав багато звинувачень,
розглядається судом як позитивний,
але він також має вагу.
З одного боку, він визнав і прийняв відповідальність,
з іншого боку, можливо, зробив це запізно.
Він також не вдавався
у деталі справи.
Адвокати Шубека вимагали
умовного терміну покарання,
зокрема посилаючись на його діяльність та співпрацю
з правоохоронними органами.
Ми обговоримо вирок з нашим клієнтом і вирішимо,
як діяти далі.
Він зробив багато неправильних речей, але,
на жаль, вже може їх змінити,
каже Шухбек.
Це гірке усвідомлення колись прославленого
зіркового шеф-кухаря.
Франкфуртська команда радіє своєму виступу
в Лізі чемпіонів, Норберте - тобі слово.
2:1 проти марсельського «Олімпіка» -
ще один сильний виступ «Айнтрахта»,
особливо в першому таймі.
Перемога в останньому матчі групи
наступного вівторка в Лісабоні -
і франкфуртці спокійно вийшли б до 1/8 фіналу.
Захоплені грою, окрилені вболівальниками,
вражені власним виступом.
Для мене це надзвичайна перемога,
тому що я просто знаю, що ці гравці завжди вкладаються
на повну
і готові поставити себе на службу команді.
І я цим неймовірно пишаюся.
Франкфуртська команда проявила себе як одиниця
з сильним характером
і вже на третій хвилині розставила перші акценти
у франкфуртському фурорі.
І 1:0.
Після зрівняння рахунку «Марселем» на
двадцять другій хвилині
Ґьотце раз по раз атакує.
Переможний пас з рахунком 2:1 від Муані.
Завдяки демонстрації сили в другому таймі
«Айнтрахт» захищає цей результат
і святкує першу домашню перемогу в Лізі чемпіонів.
Мюнхенці, які вже кваліфікувалися до 1/8 фіналу,
виграли свій п'ятий груповий матч:
3:0 в Барселоні на користь «Баварії» -
завдяки голам Мане, Шупо-Мотінга і Паварда.
«Барса» з Робертом Левандовскі вже вдруге поспіль
вилетіла з групової фази.
«Баєр Леверкузен» після нічиєї 2:2
з мадридським «Атлетіко»
з мадридським «Атлетіко»,
Вже пролунав свисток - але після втручання
відеоасистента арбітр
приймає рішення призначити пенальті у ворота
«Мадрида».
Караско пробиває - не влучає у відмінного голкіпера
«Баєра» -
удар Сауля подає Латте -
Рейнільдо також не може переправити м'яч у сітку.
Леверкузен все ще може претендувати на потрапляння
до Ліги Європи.
І від королівського класу до королівських синіх -
у «Шальке» новий тренер.
Томас Рейс стане наступником Френка Крамера,
якому не пощастило.
Раніше 49-річний тренер працював у Бохумі,
і тепер від нього очікують, що він витягне «Кнаппен»
з нижніх позицій турнірної таблиці.
Райз - вже сьомий тренер «Шальке» за останні два роки.
А перше випробування він проведе в неділю в Німеччині
проти «Фрайбурга».
І швидко прояснюємо питання,
навіщо художникам-абстракціоністам підписувати
свої роботи:
Щоб вони належно висіли в музеї.
Це безпомилково робота Мондріан:
чіткі лінії, ясні кольори.
Але без підпису вона десятиліттями висить
догори ногами.
На думку творців Музею мистецтв
Північного Рейну-Вестфалії,
таке положення правильне.
Але вони також вірять у силу звикання:
тепер картина залишається перевернутою
догори ногами.
З погодою теж все догори ногами -
завтра буде 27°, і це в кінці жовтня.
Більше від Ездена Терлі за мить.
Радимо подивитися «heute journal» 21:45
з Анною Ґеллінек.
Дякую за увагу, всього найкращого,
до зустрічі завтра.
На все добре.
Доброго вечора і ласкаво просимо до прогнозу погоди.
Цей жовтень може стати найтеплішим жовтнем
з 1881 року.
Але це не окремі місяці,
які стають теплішими, це тенденція до потепління
місяців.
Так глобальне потепління
відбивається на локальному рівні.
Та й тепло, як ви вже знаєте,
йде з південного заходу - така картина погоди
повторюється.
І ми отримуємо температуру 20-25°.
Отже, це дуже тепло стає повсюдно.
Та й вночі на півдні утвориться туман,
на крайній півночі буде більш хмарно.
З невеликими дощами - їх буде небагато.
На Заході Німеччини температура опуститься до 18°,
і до 6° - у південно-східних регіонах.
Ця карта також може бути денною.
Ось така вона помірна.
Так, а завтра, після розсіювання туману на півдні,
багато сонця, також на заході.
На решті території хмари будуть досить прозорими.
Сонячно буде й на південному заході
27° тепла,на заході - 25°, а на
біля Балтійського моря - 18°.
А наступні кілька днів продовжують бути
дуже теплими - до 26°.
Гарного вечора.